- I'VE LOST MY WIFE.
I'VE LOST MY HOUSE.
AND I'M HAVING
THE TIME OF MY LIFE.
[glasses clink]
- ♪ TODAY THERE'S A CHANGE
IN MY LIFE ♪
♪ AND I'M FEELING ALIVE ♪
- ONE FOR THE DIVORCEE SUITE.
- ♪ TODAY THERE'S A CHANGE
IN MY LIFE ♪
♪ THAT'S LIFE ♪
[phone rings]
GO FOR DR. ARMOND,
CALIFORNIA'S PREMIER
PET PLASTIC SURGEON.
- WHAT'S UP, DOC?
- OH.
KELSEY, HOW ARE YOU?
- WHAT TIME ARE WE GOING TO
HIT THE TITTY BARS?
- NOT TONIGHT,
MY FRIEND.
TONIGHT I'VE GOT A DATE.
I WAS RECENTLY INTRODUCED TO
ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
I'VE EVER MET.
I'M ENTRANCED BY HER
AND HOPE TO TAKE HER
TO A HOTEL RESTAURANT.
I'M NOT SURE IF
THE SEXUAL CHEMISTRY'S THERE,
BUT I FEEL LIKE I'VE FINALLY
FOUND A REAL PARTNER.
- PLAY THE FIELD, MY FRIEND!
PLAY THE FIELD.
[chuckles]
HOW'S YOUR HAIR?
- IT'S HOLDING UP, KELS,
BUT MY BACKHAND IS OUTTA SIGHT.
WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE
ARMOND IS AT IT AGAIN.
I'VE MADE A RESERVATION FOR US
AT THE HOTEL RESTAURANT.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
IF THERE ARE ANY SPARKS.
OH, THERE SHE IS.
WOW...
SHE LOOKS AMAZING.
HERE SHE COMES.
THE CHEMISTRY
WAS PALPABLE.
MMM.
THIS IS
VERY GOOD TORTILLA SOUP.
- YEAH,
IT'S DELICIOUS.
- HAVE YOU HAD
TORTILLA SOUP BEFORE?
- MM-HMM. I HAVE.
- MM-HMM.
- AND SO, SHANNON...
- YES, DOCTOR...
- DO YOU--?
- AR--ARMOND?
- ARMOND.
YEAH, I THINK
THAT'S MORE ROMANTIC.
I THINK
IF I CALLED YOU "DOCTOR,"
IT WOULD BE TOO MUCH
OF A PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIP.
- SURE.
SO SHANNON, TELL ME--
- YES, ARMOND?
- DO YOU HAVE HOPES AND DREAMS?
- MM-HMM.
- EVER SINCE
I SPLIT WITH MY EX,
I'M TRYING TO TURN OVER
A NEW LEAF.
I'VE GOT A NEW CAR.
IT'S A MUSTANG.
IT'S GREEN.
- MY BEETLE'S BEIGE.
[dog barking]
- IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME,
I HAVE RECEIVED A TEXT MESSAGE.
I WAS FALLING HEAD-OVER-HEELS
IN LOVE WITH SHANNON,
DESPITE KELSEY'S
BEST EFFORTS,
AND YET, THERE WAS ONE
BIG OBSTACLE STILL TO OVERCOME.
HEY, RO?
- YEAH?
- YOU READY
TO BE MY BEST MAN, ROMAN?
- FINE,
BUT I'M GONNA NEED $10,000
FOR YOUR BACHELOR PARTY.
- DEAL.
- AND YOU'RE NOT COMING.
- YOU'RE QUITE
THE NEGOTIATOR, ROMAN.
- MAYBE YOU COULD ORDER ME
A BUNCH OF FOOD
AND THEN TAKE, LIKE,
A TWO-HOUR WALK.
- ROMAN,
I LOVE YOU VERY MUCH.
- SHUT UP.
- NEXT WEEK,
ON THE TWO-HOUR SERIES FINALE
OF ARMOND ABOUT TOWN...
LET'S JUST THROW CAUTION
TO THE WALL
AND REALLY GO FOR THIS.
[wedding music]
I FEEL LIKE CINDERELLA.
- YO, I CAN'T DO
THIS WHOLE WEDDING THING.
I'M SORRY, I GOTTA GO.
PEACE, MAN.
[dramatic music]
- KELSEY, I NEED YOU
TO BE MY BEST MAN.